WikiLeaks now says that Ecuador shut
down internet access for its founder
Julian Assange he has been seeking
asylum in london's ecuadorian embassy
since 2012 to avoid extradition over sex
assault allegations and WikiLeaks
actually accused US Secretary of State
John Kerry of asking Ecuador to stop it
from publishing documents about Hillary
Clinton the US State Department
responded saying this is simply untrue
and Ecuador's foreign minister Guillaume
long made no comment on the allegations
saying quote the circumstances that led
to the granting of asylum remain uh I've
ever heard uh less clear clarification
on any issue before I don't know that I
remember so that the the backstory the
context of this of course is that
WikiLeaks has been releasing emails
relating to affecting Hillary Clinton's
campaign including emails obtained
through uh from campaign chairman John
Podesta Z email many of these relate to
campaign strategy some of these relate
to conversations with media outlets that
if you didn't know any better you would
think we're not coordinating media
coverage to be advantageous to Hillary
Clinton but were merely reporting on the
Hillary Clinton campaign uh there was a
BBC call made to the Ecuadorian Embassy
weren't able to get through to anybody a
woman who picked up the phone reportedly
said quote I cannot disclose any
information I'm getting a ton of email
and Twitter comments and facebook
comments YouTube from people saying
Assange is going to be killed soon can't
you see what's going on David this is
close to the end for Assange there's of
course the logistical issue if Assange
is inside the Ecuadorian Embassy it's
going to be hard to kill him unless
you're coming up with a plot that would
be difficult to believe even if it were
part of like a Bourne movie but we do
see at least allegations that the
Ecuadorian Embassy may be reaching its
limit as far as Julian Assange is
concerned unclear right because they've
been so cryptic in their statement
but let's take a step back from the sort
of logistics of it it's more or less
widely accepted that Assange and
WikiLeaks have a sort of Deadman switch
set up on a ton of data so the way that
this works is something along the lines
of every 24 hours or maybe 48 hours or
72 who knows every so often Julian
Assange has to check in or activate some
kind of digital Deadman switch so this
might be he has to log on to a certain
website or maybe send an email with a
very particular string of characters to
some inbox that is automatically
monitored some kind of signal that he's
still alive with the idea being that if
he were to be killed he would not be
able to flip the Deadman switch and some
data would automatically be released the
problem with that and and i genuinely
i've been researching this during the
morning and i don't have a clear answer
on the one hand it's pretty what widely
accepted that Julian Assange and
WikiLeaks have some kind of a Deadman
switch scenario established but on the
other hand Julian Assange has said many
times that WikiLeaks as a matter of
policy doesn't sit on material to be
released at some kind of maximum uh at
some optimal time for maximum political
impact the the claim from Assange has
been we receive the material we start
vetting it we read act as needed and
then we release it so I I don't really
understand how you can simultaneously be
holding blockbuster data with a Deadman
switch that will be released if you're
killed and failed to to set reset the
Deadman switch but at the same time you
say we don't sit on anything everything
we get that is a value we release as
soon as it's been redacted and taken
care of if that's not a contradiction
please email me and let me know what it
is that I'm missing because I don't
really get it my thoughts on
specifically the cutting of Julian
Assange is internet it's a little silly
in that WikiLeaks is not not a
one-person operation it's only Julian
Assange at the Ecuadorian Embassy it's
it's more symbolic and meaning i have no
doubt that Julian Assange is involved in
some of the major decisions made
WikiLeaks but there is ZERO question
knowing everything we do about the
organization and about Julian Assange
that there is some plan where things
proceed even if you can't get ahold of
Julian Assange so from a strategic
perspective it doesn't really make sense
maybe UK uh-uh broadband providers have
instituted data caps like we're seeing
here in the US and assigns was just uh
over it at the Embassy and it's a simple
and explanation is that I don't really
think so but maybe at some point we'll
figure it out